Hey,
sooner or later
, it must have been destined to be like this
I know,
first of all, I want you to look at this picture
[music]
Hey,
why am I here?
Even if I was doing it with
you,
I'm moving We won't be able to see each other
Mother
[music]
But it's
okay We'll meet again when we grow up
Because
we're fiancés
So why can't you read my mind?
That's right Nagi-kun,
you had the same face as when Coon's delusions were exploding,
Char.
That's right,
because they're brothers, Sousuke Ame No, he
's
my older brother and a brother and sister who's related to Nagi-kun by blood.
Surprise, I had an older brother in
what ward?
It seems like I
don't have a heart, maybe I don't have a
heart